à paris c'est le célèbre pont neuf
n'aura pas froid cet automne l'artiste
christo val habillé pourquoi cette drôle
d'initiative
comment s'y prendra-t-il sylvie marion
et jacquot bertha répondent à notre
curiosité
un projet fou une oeuvre d'art tout à
fait inhabituels comme paris n'en a
jamais connu est en train de voir le
jour
cet homme un artiste l'américain
d'origine bulgare cristaux se donne pour
but d'enveloppés drapé dans du tissu
empaqueter le pont neuf comme un immense
cadeau offert aux parisiens fin
septembre pour 15 jours
voici le projet de cristaux il ne
changera en rien la vie des parisiens ce
clochard pourrez dormir comme d'habitude
dans la même position sous celle que
l'imposition c'est d'ailleurs bien sûr
tous les routes sera couvert de seth
ward la toile les destinées d'un patient
très spécial est retenu par onze
kilomètres l'écart développe et aussi
les voitures qui veut dire une parcelle
les bateaux mouches où les bretons les
prétendants marchait sur le bord des
trottoirs et des douars aussi les
voitures sur la voie georges pompidou
vont passer librement
si le projet monumental de cristaux est
fou la réalisation elle est des plus
sérieuses une dizaine d'entreprises du
travail
douze ingénieurs dirige une centaine
d'exécutants 200 personnes oeuvreront
sur le site
ici tout l'été à lui valent rave
armentières on assemble 40 mètres carrés
des toiles pauliani couleur pierre de
paris
complètement et cela à coucher par les
nouilles qui vont payer mais ça y est
c'est la ouvert par les eaux finisse et
va tomber
l'espoir est accablant nous ne ferons
aucune fixation dans le pont le pont
sera entièrement maintenu dans son état
et tous les risques d'accident de gros
accident était prévu je crois la
projection d'un film américain réalisé
sur une de ses oeuvres exécutées dans
les montagnes du colorado
c'est ce que kristo a tenu à montrer aux
ouvriers d'armentières qui m'épate le
russe en fait avait simplement pensé à
faire ce conflit parce que je pense que
c'est quand même
en fait et
c'est ça le vrai problème c'est avait
repensé imaginer autre chose que ce
qu'on fait habituellement
et je pense que ça c'est faute à la
reprise pour personne mais tout
en fait l'idée originale est de pouvoir
faire profiter à tout le monde sait
garder sa liberté politique de tous vous
êtes contente de travailler sur le pont
neuf oui bien sûr
ça change vraiment où habituellement
travail sont des tentes quelque chose de
frais normal ici trop neuf c'est
vraiment quelque chose des fraudes et
d'extraordinaire je veux pas vous
définir mais
vraiment tout ruzyne y participent il
faut savoir que kristo finance
entièrement seul tous les travaux sans à
subventions en vendant les dessins
collages préparatoire à son oeuvre
avis aux collectionneurs si tout se
déroule comme prévu les parisiens
vivront à la fin de l'été un moment
poétique collectif sans doute unique
dans l'histoire de la capitale